welcome back to another episode of worth
it watches worth it that's us from the
show worth it watching worth it okay
Adam what are we watching today so in
another episode of worth it watches you
reveal yours and here we're about to
reveal mine we're watching worth it
Korean soups no way that doesn't
surprise me actually because I know you
love David change what's your favorite
episode it's like what's your favorite
child like everyone actually has one but
you do actually love all of them even if
you do have a favorite these drawings by
the way yeah great drawings so that's
actually an interesting throwback to I
remember in the original Korean BBQ
episode we were getting the drawings
made for this section of the video and I
used to just go up to this other
employee named Maggie and I would and I
would say hey I know you're good at
drawing would you mind just doing like
the quickest doodle you can of these
three foods and she did it in like less
than 10 minutes and then that's what was
in the video they're always great and
now we have a very you know professional
workflow where we you know utilize one
of our illustrators at work and they
make these awesome drawings yeah so I
have really not wanted to feature this
restaurant for a long time right because
if you're gonna find me someone okay
go to hon but I'll probably be there I
eat there quite a bit I'm not gonna eat
there Saturday I mean it's gonna be this
video already be I'll yeah yeah like
heaven I have a friend date there yeah
so those are photos from your actual
photo role sure actually
yeah so I have an album caught selling
Tom on my out of my photo album I like
this sliding mood shot it's like the
one that they have an Italian
restaurants when they're like cutting
the meat sure yeah the cool Korean
version this is really interesting so
the guy just wears these like thermal
protective gloves and he dips this
stoneware bowl into the pot of soup to
pre warm it so that your bowl gets hot
mm-hmm and behind-the-scenes bonus of
this video he both he gave us both bowls
yes I use it very often I use it very
often tea really what are you cooking it
like everything I eat borscht out of it
no you don't the idea I have a picture
on my phone actually Wow yeah that's my
Ukrainian borscht in the sewing tongue
bold also a beef soup it's a great bowl
I've considered just replacing all my
bowls with those oh man that was insane
yeah he's wearing a white t-shirt yeah
yeah the white hanji like that seems not
practical at all this is one of those
times where we get an understanding of
what we're gonna be able to film you
know the owners like okay you guys can
film the kimchi and then we go and film
it and we're like this is how you make
this this is wild
like just such a large quantity they
have some of the best Kim G yo down by
the way it is so good for real
I mean
[Music]
baru
is a literal hidden gem for real this is
probably the fanciest food in the whole
episode like even more intense than
major demo that we go to it a very in
third location oh those were so good for
real they also sell jars of pickles Tom
your tongue don't Jimmy cooks ooh so
firm soup fell on Tom my head is
spinning with Sears Korea did what is
that can you eat it we'll make it a soup
no my favorite lines of yours oh yeah I
think it's because it sounds like you
said it do you think our commentary has
like oh no intermixed over the seasons
like you say stuff more like me I stay
stuff more like you it's actually a
popular like in the most recent season a
lot of commenters are like wow I was
Stephen and Andrew of like switched
personalities it's true which actually
makes a lot of sense if you think about
it for the way that the show works like
we're almost like a relay team right hmm
you start somewhere crazy go to the
sensical place hand me the baton I'm in
the sensible place and I go to outer
space
that's so good yeah I hand it back to
you where you're waiting for how to
bring it back say Arthur it yes
we're now on our way to honestly one of
my favorite restaurants called spoon by
H I think I say that like three
different times you definitely do so I
probably shouldn't say this but if
you're gonna find me somewhere it'll be
a hot if you're gonna find an answer
somewhere it's gonna be a spoon by H so
wanna photo
hey by H alright it's so good no yeah
whoo there is beautiful it's this is
when I was starting to get annoyed at
how good the show God like the lighting
is also so on point here which by the
way we don't bring licenses to our
shoots people like okay how did you do
that it's like I don't know just you
know to learn camera to the wizard
behind the camera often it's shutting
all the lights it's
tae-bo we're making the dumplings this
way oh my god that will live in infamy
Wow
I watched that export maybe 25 times
this is one of the most insane things
they actually slice each of these grapes
by they you literally does it one by one
oh this waffle there's nothing like the
swallows ever had it's fluffy and crispy
and it is this bowl for the fruit it's I
feel like I'm in the patients right now
yeah it feels like something that is
spiderling oh yeah fighter you think
crawly bugs but then you see its Web
you're like how could nature produce
such a perfect shape someone check you
in for a radioactive spider bite Peter
Parker more like something that I don't
know food or man I remember thinking so
hard about it like it's not in the Edit
but there's a period of time when I'm
just like mulling over it and then I say
it and I regret it but then it's the
best in the video we're gonna see David
Chang and there is he's going to show us
their whole boiled chicken meat like
horse shoes because he's a friend of the
show he's going to be classic blurring
out stuff that doesn't need to be
blurred out joining us for our meal also
because it's quite a large this is a
multi-course soup extravaganza oh yeah I
will always call him Davey poop behind
his back don't worry what's the story
behind Davey poo uh so after we shot
with him and I was intimidated by him
you know in Korea for the first time I
realized he was just you know this
lovable huggable guy you know so then I
realized he should just be called Davey
poo which happened right after we
finished shooting with him in Korea then
it goes in the edit and now his staff
some of his staff and you don't call him
Davey poo I'm glad we could create that
social lubrication I think it's funny
that this the
next video we made with David Chang is
also a whole chicken like the first time
was the whole fried chicken alright that
thumbnail by the way for that is outta
control straight fire where the chicken
looks like it's about to jump out at you
and then this one where doesn't done
that for this one it's the spoon by aged
soup ah okay yeah I mean like okay so so
actually I have Malaysian friends who
asked me how was this chicken rice
because you know they always like our
comparing chicken rises in Malaysia yeah
but it was very distinctly flavorful
like I think chicken rice in Malaysia
it's like it kind of has a like a I
don't want a grungy but like a homey
feel right and this definitely felt like
a little bit more first flavor burst hmm
yeah but I would recommend you order it
just like if you order this and you know
chicken rice don't expect what you're
gonna get at home this is like the
classic David Chang right like take a
dish you know and combine it with four
other dishes yeah and like he's able to
see the harmony of callers that come
together yeah okay this is I love this
woman and pretty sure the soup cost like
$30 more based on yeah thanks for 10
seconds of truffle and full disclosure
uh-huh we had plans to film this without
truffle right because it's a different
ingredient set seasonally so like the
soup doesn't necessarily have morel
mushrooms or truffles and when we saw it
most recently on the menu it didn't have
truffles listed there then we got there
and it was like oh you guys are gonna do
the truffle he's like yeah we're gonna
be the truck like you should have it
like the the most elevated way well why
do you say that like I think it's
important to distinguish why we went in
not planning to future the truffle well
because I didn't think it was available
and and also it wasn't like
the focus of the like narrative of the
video necessarily that's that's kind of
where I'm going at it's like sometimes
people will dismiss the quality of the
dish if you just like quote-unquote add
truffles at the end it's like no it's
expensive but no there's like so much
more that is going into it
even without the truffle for sure like
subtract the truffle and it's still yeah
it's so like a 70 something dollar dish
yeah but hey which is actually pretty
reasonable like yeah because it's you're
sharing this dish Oh beautiful thinking
this is a very simple dish but it's so
freakin good yeah why you talking like
that yeah he looks like he's he's like
sheriff is like we're tinfoil hats on
guys the chickens been domesticated he's
like looking around the room we're in an
empty restaurant he's like chickens been
domesticated whenever we eat with David
I realized that food is the greatest
vehicle for conversation no matter who
you are even if you quote unquote
dislike well-regarded chef Davie but
like it doesn't matter who you are like
we can all connect on the basis of food
that's part of your show is it yeah
that's right David Chang is a Adam
stander to soup which soup what's the
most worth it to you I just get the
first one this is a hard one I think of
all the expensive restaurants there are
in Los Angeles
majordomo actually offers some of the
best you have made Elmo only my spoon
please yeah only one of the best
restaurants in all of Los Angeles
oh and you're worth a winner my with a
winner goes to hahnsbach song you know
okay boss after this video came out I
had a lot of friends the amber text me
and saying thank you for picking Homme
but you know what's up cuz like it's
like og k-town spots been there for so
long it's been like the place for you
know generations passed down it's like
the plastic is soup that has made song
Tom on the mat for so many people you
know I could not pick humba commune it's
legit it is super good there that's my
current favorite episode tomorrow it
might be something else it might be
cheesecake it might be worth it hotels
okay so that was worth it watches we're
gonna be doing more of these with more
fun subjects there's any watchings that
you'd like to recommend please feel free
to comment and thanks for watching
thanks for we watched now that you've
watched thanks
[Music]